cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com New York City to pay over 1
billion dollars to house illegal
immigrants over the next three years oh
boy enjoy that yeah they say with the
migrant crisis and the Big Apple showing
no signs of slowing down anytime soon
mayor Eric Adams has proposed extending
the city's contract with the hotel
association of New York the plan to
house illegal immigrants until August
2026 is expected to bring the project
cost since the Crisis began to 1.35
billion dollars my manager is having an
aneurysm right now in New York well you
should be so people are outraged and
there's a video from this morning where
the police arrest the locals protesting
the non-citizens being paid and brought
into their homes not literal homes their
their neighborhoods is this Roosevelt
Hotel no this is Staten Island okay in
Staten Island locals came out and said
stay out of our communities and the
police arrest arrested them Michael
Mouse is not wrong about police oh yeah
he's totally right blind approved it
those cops held those cars there as
children burned to death and they they
don't they don't they're building
something on your side but the
government they don't know or care and
look I people misunderstand this they
think that the idea that a cop would do
this when Michael malice says when
Michael malice says that police will
commit there's there's no crime so
egregious police officer we're not
committed up into including the
execution of children what people think
he's saying is that cops are smirking me
what he's saying is that a cop will be
told don't let these cars leave and they
go sure thing boss and then they're all
roasting alive he's like oh that's
what's happening that's what Jordan
Peterson talked about with the Nazi
officers and and what people are saying
now about what's happening in New York
and the immigration crisis
they bring in non-citizens they then say
you can be police officers Illinois is
proposing this they then say how would
you like to be a citizen all you got to
do is join the military join the
National Guard now you have loyal uh
people with no loyalty to the
Constitution or the country being
promised personal gain to subjugate
anyone who would stand against them we
already have that I mean you can already
earn citizenship if you're an illegal if
you're right but that's not my point my
point is if you do it on Moss we have a
really big problem I understand that my
point is not that we allow people to
become citizens to the military that I
get my point is
if a right if an American citizen is
questioned will you take up arms against
your neighbor they'll say no outright No
One Believes that police would do these
things because the assumption is the
police officers are consciously deciding
to harm a child
the real issue is that the police will
follow orders without understanding what
the full ramifications are and just do
it but there still is a problem of
American versus American but you bring
in non-americans Empower them with law
enforcement capabilities and weapons and
they'll say I literally don't care about
you at all I'm getting mine and there's
all of these young men these young
military age men that we see crossing
the border
um just wandering on it and not caring
at all the bite Administration will
maintain that it's actually families in
these points even though they're not and
then also what happens is these young
men in a lot of cases when you see them
with families these are like cartel
manufactured families no they're not
really you know they're not actually
related they're not actually involved
with one another
um yeah I think this is really scary the
Roosevelt Hotel also has been taken over
by the city and is used to house
migrants exclusively and what's really
interesting about that is the Roosevelt
Hotel is owned by a Pakistani company
Jacqueline toboroff for human events
uncovered this for us it's owned by a
Pakistani company that New York City is
paying for the privilege of housing
migrants in it
and I'm nervous about a lot of hotels
like going to stay in a hotel in New
York who are you going to end up being
with a bunch of people who are living
there like cooking on hot pots in the
rooms and like you won't be like what's
going on so we him in Britain we've been
dealing with this for a couple years now
you guys have a barge right didn't you
guys set up a barge no we've done jack
no there was a barge Rishi sunach
put up a barge oh it just didn't happen
yeah so in in Britain we're paying three
billion pounds a year to house them and
hotels and there's a local migrant hotel
near our offices near the load seaters
offices and we walk past there every day
to go and get our lunch and it's full of
Africans we're just sitting around
smoking and drinking with a very
suspicious collection of bikes that are
tied up these bikes are all quite old
and Rusty looking some have got flat
tires these guys have been in the
country six months how did you get such
a rusty bike you don't think they
brought their antique bike collection
with them yeah I don't um but this is
costing us money and if you go on the
website for this particular Hotel it's
just booked in perpetuity the whole
thing right so the government will just
book out the entire hotel in perpetuity
so you actually don't have to worry
about having to share a room with them
or anything you're in no danger of that
because you're just paying for their
holiday
how lovely perpetuity how lovely so are
we going to take we're taking our cues
from Britain on this one too
unfortunately yeah really quite a shame
it's really really annoying and uh for
some reason our government won't do
anything about it but again okay so
coming back to the previous Point what's
the right plan how are you retaking New
York aren't we going to build a wall
around New York no it's not a big city
it comes back to the whole thing you
can't be asking to be left alone they
won't leave you alone what's the plan to
take New York the plan well to take New
York I don't know I don't know of an
immediate plan but the best thing that
I'm aware of right now is to do
everything we can to get the the
Communist influence out of the the
global Economist influence out of
schools right now okay get out good but
but like that isn't a soon thing yeah
New York used to have like California as
well used to be a republican place like
they sat there with them George Pataki
they they had a plan and they had the
money they had the resource and they got
the activists they had the will to drive
out their opponents and they've done it
and they will sit that will never be
Republican again it will it will always
be this kind of part yeah Texas is
purple State man and yeah this this
creeping Advance has always been the
plan and they're successful so what's
the right plan to roll it back how are
you taking care of your castles no one's
got no one's got a plan no have you
played uh we need a Grendel no what we
need is a billionaires do we have what
are the right-wing billionaires doing
like I completely
agreement millionaires here's what
they're doing Brothers where's my money
how much money have you been given
I've been given none exactly neither
have I one well you know to be fair some
rich guys did give me uh they're cool
dudes they're they're I I want to make
sure they give you a handshake and a
beer right no I've been getting a
thousand dollars uh uh maybe five six
seven years ago I got when I was just
the small YouTube channel when when you
would post I was 100 000 Subs I did have
a patreon a patron who gave me 500 bucks
a month that's amazing and uh uh almost
a billionaire guy yeah but uh I I will
say
there are a handful of dudes that
definitely deserve credit for for
pushing back but I will also say I
question this all the time how is it
that Tim cast bought 36 Billboards in
Times Square last year 36 that the year
we we had What's called the North End
domination which is the entire North
Tower on New Year's we were in the
rotation of ads where every I think 90
seconds the whole thing except for the
McDonald's I love that you had lucrative
that's right and Michael malice yeah
yeah because I'm like this is our our
push into the cultural spaces this uh uh
the the total cost I believe for two
weeks of the North End domination run
with New Year's was two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars we are no like
that's a lot for us oh yeah and I'm
wondering where all of these other
powerful people I'm not even talking
about billionaires millionaires Yep
they're not doing anything like this
where are the right wing ngos that are
training activists to have a slate of
arguments and instructions in order to
go into institutions and start turning
them right wing but let me know
I have a question for you have you
played the video game forbidden West all
right Horizon forbidden
I haven't I even heard cultural
reference but I'll keep it simple for
you sure uh spoiler alert for anybody
who hasn't finished the second game that
came out several months ago uh the world
ends AI robots go go Rogue destroy the
planet that's game one yeah game two
you're in Silicon Valley Los Angeles
area uncovering more data you discover
that there was something there was a
military operation that everybody
participated in everyone it was they
were giving everyone weapons and saying
You must fight because we need to buy
enough time for our super weapon which
will defeat the AI the the Rogue swarm
and so everybody said let's go
a young woman a hacker discovered there
actually was no super weapon the program
was actually a terraforming operation
that Humanity would be killed and
everyone be grinded into Pace but they
needed to make sure that everybody gave
their result that gave everything they
had because if if that 60 year old man
didn't take up and fight back to buy
more time then they would not be able to
build the terraforming system which
would eventually give Humanity a rebirth
right the point was
many people were without hope and ready
to just lay down and give up and
although they did not believe they could
win they needed to tell everyone you we
are winning you will win do not give up
otherwise all is lost so I my point is
this
I genuinely believe we have gone to mate
we've begun to make such massive
cultural strides Victory is genuinely
possible I think that's true I also
think it's important to point out being
off being as honest as I can we cannot
maintain the idea or promote the idea
that we've lost already we can't win
there's no plan and nothing you do will
work because then what happens
there was a viral tweet where someone
said no one is trying to solve the
problems they're only trying to get rich
enough of the problems don't apply to
them anymore yeah and when you tell
people you have lost and you can't win
then then everyone says well then what
am I doing so I'm not trying to say that
it can't be done what I'm saying is
given the way that the war works now the
right is just not equipped to win the
war that's the problem it's we know
exactly how this war can be won because
we can see exactly how the left is
winning it the problem is that right has
just got no organizational skills and no
defined end goal like the the if the
right should have some clear view of
what they want the country to look like
because the left absolutely have a clear
view it's just monstrous well right and
they're working they're working to
implement this and so the right knows or
should know by this point it needs
billionaire backing it needs ngos it
needs an army of bureaucrats and it
needs weird obsessive people on social
media to constantly reinforce every
single thing this structure does and it
needs to start consciously trying to
take care Apostles like institutions of
influence and maintain them actively
gatekeep against left-wing people
infiltrating them in return which is
precisely what they do and make sure
that every like I mean you look at
universities where something like 95 of
professors are left-wing like that okay
where's the 95 right-wing ones where are
these institutions the right has already
lost almost everything
and there's one and there's one right
out in Florida but let me let me tell
you about Charlestown West Virginia
West Virginia the second most Trump
supporting state in the country where
you have signs not even in West Virginia
in Western Maryland you have signs that
say Maga Trump Flags everywhere you're
in West Virginia sure Jefferson County
which is the Eastern Panhandle is still
substantially more Progressive with a
lot more Democrats and liberals coming
from DC but it is still majority Trump
supporting Charlestown West Virginia
passed a pride month resolution and the
residents are outraged and Furious but
guess what they don't vote and so uh
Sheamus was here and there's a large
Christian Catholic procession where they
protested I don't know if it was just
this issue and I talked to a member of
the city council because there's only a
handful and he and I said there were
thousands of people protesting in
Charlestown that the city passed this
resolution for pride month and he said
they don't vote why don't they vote
because conservative people on the right
don't organize they don't organize they
don't this is so this is what we're
doing right
we're building anti-time Square we're
building the Public Square if you know I
I say that because it sounds awesome but
you know I got to talk to Public Square
if they if they're happy with that and
uh first thing we're doing is we set up
a coffee shop and that should be opening
in a few months
it's getting pushed back because of
Permitting it's hard to do and uh second
floor Social Club Tim cast members
you're gonna have a blast we're gonna
have you know like a bar we're gonna
have you know card tables whatever we
can legally have I don't know we'll see
we're working on the card tables
um you better watch movies hang out work
on projects then we're going to set up
cousin T's Diner Terence Williams gonna
have a gonna have a pancake restaurant
we're gonna do Papa Jack's Pizza Shack
Family Pizza Restaurant we are going to
create this whole strip which is
effectively a parallel Times Square
small town protecting the generational
businesses that have been there
my goal with cast Brew Coffee we're
working with Andrew gruel on a franchise
plan is that we we get people who are
interested in the mission here's our
plan for infiltration in all of these
places we set up a coffee shop in strip
malls in every major city wherever
people live and they're interested in
doing it when soccer mom who doesn't pay
attention all that much is on our way to
pick up the kids from soccer practice
and says I need to get me a cold brew
she types in her little Google map
coffee and Casper coffee pops up right
next to the Target she drives in and
walks in she walks the counter and says
I'll just do a large cold brew it's like
you got it and as she's waiting she's
looking looking around there's TVs on
the wall playing Stephen Crowder and
she's listening to the conversation from
these shows or Viva Fray or trigonometry
and she's sitting there she's getting
their concert goes thank you and she
looks up and they're saying here's the
video of the barisma Scandal that no one
wants you to know about here's Joe Biden
saying he did it and she goes huh and
that is how we get cultural hubs all
throughout that's a great start but then
think about how far Advanced the left
are in this war yup absolutely we've I
know I'm not like I said I'm not saying
we can't win I'm just saying it's going
to take some actual leg work and and
this is what we're doing but I will add
this this move we are making with uh
beginning the uh beginning the process
by which we can franchise Casper
the left has not done this what the left
has done is infiltrated existing
corporations and that's powerful but
there's something more powerful in
they're like the parasite ants they
don't have that they don't have the
support
what they have is clever strategy they
move into West Virginia claim to be
conservative and then get on school
boards and start corrupting and
destroying from within but most people
oppose them what we have is patriotism
which means people are actually willing
to work on a project like this because
it means something so you're saying like
where are the with the ideologues who
are like gonna you know just just get
into the pro like start working on this
and just dedicate themselves to winning
they're here and and we've got tons of
requests for people who want to open
these shops we just need to get it's
legal paperwork and all the different
things that's great that's a great stuff
yeah but here's why I agree with you
timcast does not have
that much money relative to the tens of
billions that they have but not not them
I'm saying like I don't want to drag
anyone in particular right now
but there was a meeting in Austin Texas
with billionaires and almost
billionaires and I was there with some
some friends
um
and they were talking about solutions to
how do we win the culture War and the
problem was these people and I mean this
in the quite literal and most respectful
sense quite literally I believe many of
them are autistic in that they have a
general light sense of autism they don't
understand social cues social issues
cultural issues their entire approach
was technological and analytical and
they don't understand how you win a
culture war and so I'm there with some
very prominent culture Warriors and
we're like guys listen Okay I said you
want to win the culture War someone
needs to just give Michael malice like
10 million dollars a year and just say
like you are can you imagine the damage
to the left Michael malice could do with
funding that is a huge thing though I
mean money is a huge part of it you know
because conservatives need to be okay
with losing money in order to win
elections and win culture and right now
conservatives for the most part are not
you know they look out at the you know
whatever their Enterprises are and they
say let me just hang on to the money let
me just you know Break Even or whatever
they don't really they're not really
aware of the fact that if you're going
to win any of this stuff you have to be
fine with losing money all of these big
leftist organizations lose money
constantly but the benefits think about
BuzzFeed BuzzFeed when a Pulitzer on the
Steele dossier they lost all their money
all the time
what the left is after and I truly
believe this is access to power so it's
proximity is what the the payments but
that's why they can lose the money
that's why BuzzFeed can because BuzzFeed
doesn't care about the dollars because
the only thing money is good for is
exercising power right nobody wants
money just because they have money
nobody wants dollars for dollars nobody
wants pounds for pounds they want money
because it it facilitates exercising
power so if you can if you can how much
money a barisma spend on Hunter Biden
just to get access to his dad but but
the so what what they're doing is
essentially they're foregoing the actual
cash like BuzzFeed four goes cash to be
in good graces with people in positions
of power and right now the right doesn't
have that like the right has there's
there's the only person in a position of
power not in the government the only
person in a significant position of
power that a right-leaning person could
go ahead and and try to get access to
that that could help them would be
someone like musk or maybe maybe Joe Joe
Rogan I would argue too that there are
conservative billionaires conservative
wealthy people who sent their children
to Liberal Elite institutions and then
our influence to not speak out I mean I
I know personally from when I Source
fundraiser there are a lot of
conservatives who are saying well but my
my kids would be so upset if I donated
to this or if I did that or the other
and so you are have this family pressure
to not do anything and I think that is
sort of the cowardice we have to shed
moving forward I think ultimately there
are a lot of reasons why people want to
hold on to their money and especially if
you win conservative you tend to be
family oriented so probably you want to
pass down your money to your kids but if
your kids are all voting for Joe Biden
maybe it's not good enough to hand it to
them maybe that's not worth the
investment
you you'd be thinking why is my child
become a communist and I'm a republican
what have I done wrong who has done this
to them surely you want to take revenge
on that person I'm sure you want to be
like right I'm going to make sure that
person never works again right how dare
you do this to me you know that's what
the right should be thinking to the
right is just like well I just only work
about uh leave me alone any minute so
then the right is going to lose with
this app so what do you think aside from
things that like like you're doing with
lotus heaters it'll be like Tim's doing
here what is it that you think the right
should be doing
um right the right the right should be
trying to craft policy right but the
problem with that is that you need an
affirmative ideological goal in order to
be able to craft a suite of policies and
the problem with not having an
affirmative ideological goal is that it
really comes down to ultimately the
right has to have more than just
liberalism right it has to be more than
the government isn't allowed to tax me
or take my stuff right it has to be what
should you do today what should you do
and the problem with liberalism has no
answer to that liberalism is an entirely
negative Doctrine right and this is why
like Christianity was considered to be a
core part of life for the original
classical liberals because that did have
a normative doctrine of action and the
doctrine of action that the left has is
is all any number of a variety
exactly it's it's totally changing
there's no limit to the scope of what
the left need right and so the right
needs to be looking at themselves and
going okay what is it actually that the
world should look like and really what
it should be is safe for children right
that should be the watchword of the
right we're going to make the world safe
for children oh sorry got some gangsters
I know they're arrested oh what about
human rights okay repeal that safe for
children oh there's some people in El
Salvador oh 50 000 March frog marched
through the street humiliated back to
you know back to back heads down whipped
as they go the humiliation safe for
children humiliation for criminals right
this is what the right should be saying
all day every day if you find anything
because now suddenly you have a mandate
what are you doing over there oh I'm
coming over there you're I'm
getting you safe for children
that's really good right this is why you
should put me in charge yeah I'm telling
you I'm just saying that are you looking
for like a specific position
generational perspective just for a year
well I think you can get it I think in
the spirit of uh the Goodwill of our
neighbors across the pond when we look
to this culture war and we seek an ally
akin to the French that intervened on
our behalf perhaps it will be the
British maybe I'd love it if it was the
case
because we are so wouldn't it be
cool if we could be like the British are
coming and it wasn't like
needs it's rallying Christ and I think
making the world safe for children is a
really great one because it encompasses
literally every aspect of life yeah like
that's a good one like when I was a kid
man you would just go out you would just
go out you would just go and your
parents were like look get out of the
house I don't want you around yeah come
back when it gets dark oh you're hungry
right have you read the first the fourth
turning so uh this is exactly what it's
talking about it's talking about our
generation of like you know the sort of
gen xers who grew up uh kind of nomadic
with our parents just having no idea
where we are with literal advertisements
coming on at 10 pm saying Do You Know
Where Your Children Are you know they
had to like what crazy times
that they had children but it talks
about how that generation that grew up
like that would grow up to say to the
world let's make it safe for children
yep that would be nice because we should
be that's the thing and how could you
argue against it right exactly who's
arguing against it I can and well this
is how the left have won everything
because I've been like oh you're a
racist I'm not a racist you can't argue
against right so we need our own
mimetics like that but so I disagree
with the uh I agree with the general
idea you're saying because I understand
you and I know what you mean yeah but we
have to be careful to avoid snowplow
parenting create that helicopter thing
and creating a soft generation of weak
kids who are scared of everything but
right now
that's the best learning thing but he's
talking when he says say for children
he's saying it should be safe for
children to be in the world helicopter
parenting means that you're protecting
your children yeah and it's a perfectly
good distinction to make but but Phil
you're exactly right it's safe for
children to go and explore yeah right
they're not going to get kidnapped
they're not going to fall into a gang
they're not going to get drugged up they
won't stop there and it takes oh yeah
yeah
it takes fathers that are capable of
violence to protect their society in
order to make it safe for children and
that means that you need men thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time